hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast and check it in on you
it starts day everybody case you're
losing count out there it's Thursday
July 16th even though I think most
people are kind of back to work on some
level even though I heard they're gonna
shut down California again because you
know we're not doing what we need to do
I don't know what else to tell you we're
just not doing what the [ __ ] we need to
do what's embarrassing and I'm sick of
talking about it but guess what take no
wait let me do the newly The Cove it
don't take but if I like Trump I'm not
wearing a mask
you [ __ ] i don'ti know what the
[ __ ] I'm watching at home but I can't
smell grass cuz I'm sitting in my
[ __ ] living room waiting for
mouth-breathers to just do what the CDC
says or else Ponzi schemes gonna
collapse and we'll all have to eat each
other alright I shouldn't just signal at
Trump people there you also like young
people in that type of [ __ ] you know I
went I got a you know I smashed my cell
phone screen I forget who I initially
did it and just kept getting worse and
worse and I was going to eventually get
it fixed
oh I Mumbai smashed it in the [ __ ]
Apple store that's right because they
weren't helping me with what I needed to
help and I was throwing [ __ ] back in my
bag and I didn't realize my phone was
underneath it that's how I initially
cracked it then I kept going and going
and going so whatever so I ended up got
to the point where I was wearing the old
sweatpants Oh Billie workout
Oh Billie
cold buns of steel there I had my spiked
sweatpants on and it just update people
who missed the podcast I was getting
into a car and as I was closing the door
you know sweatpants had just slid out of
the pants and got the old Malati crunch
for you Happy Days fans out there
between the door and the car cell phone
in the middle being the meat on the
sandwich there so then I couldn't even
do anything on the screen and bla bla
bla bla bla so ended up getting a new
phone cuz all the Apple stores were
closed and I found this person that
actually repairs screen so I just had
the thing [ __ ] repaired finally God
did it in an hour
his it was guy working by himself you
know the other worker didn't show up
that day he was answering phones and he
still with all the customers and all
that [ __ ] still got me out of there in
an hour
he said I'll have this thing done in an
hour and I'm sitting in there and then
watch this [ __ ] guy Cubs Jersey take
me out to the ballgame he's wearing a
mask his buddy comes in no [ __ ] mask
young kids right and then another one of
that friends comes in he's young kid and
he's walked as he's walking into the
store he's starting to put his on so I
don't know and somebody else was showing
me how parents are starting to have like
these parties where if one kid is
infected with Cova Dallow level of CO
vid whatever from their non-medical
having [ __ ] asses
they're just diagnosing that and then
they're just trying to give it to other
kids so they get the antibodies and as
far as I know that there's no proof that
once you get the antibodies that once
they go away you can't get it again I
don't know what the [ __ ] people are
doing I haven't heard anybody with a lab
coat and a degree saying that that's
what you should be doing but people are
go all the work and this is what happens
this is what happens when you're a
divided country because of [ __ ] you
only have two news networks but now I
think they really need to be they need
to be broke it up but what the [ __ ] do I
know I'm just a goddamn comedian so
don't listen to me I will tell you this
I watched that MotoGP race MotoGP is
coming back this Sunday the full [ __ ]
Mon
t-there where I watched the MotoGP Qatar
race from in March March 8th right
before this whole thing shut down was a
MotoGP to race well for those who are
race fans that's like the triple-a and
Joe Roberts the California kid an
American had a great showing
there was some guy forget his [ __ ]
name the guy was like he was winning the
ho damn race and Joe Roberts was
pressuring him and he kind of ate up his
tires did this guy and then for a minute
Joe Roberts was in first place an
American on a motorcycle winning and
just below the tippity-top of the
motorcycle sports world and it was very
exciting
he had the stars and stripes on his
helmet which I loved and but I hope I
say it right tatsuta Nagashima it's
Japanese writer who just wrote an
incredible race ended up passing him and
then a couple of Italians also passed
him Lorenzo Baldessari and Ania
Bastian e uno Bastian Nene
Bastian Eenie right they all pass him so
now he wasn't on the podium but it was
still a great showing for the young kid
I'm open you know he's gonna do some
things in MotoGP too and we'll get an
American we'll get a ride up on MotoGP
but
pig nose is it all starts back up the
real deal and I'm saying you know if
you're living in the United States of
America for whatever dumb reason they
don't televise it over here they used to
on Fox Sports but they stopped MotoGP
you can only watch on MotoGP comm I
highly highly recommend it if you're
into racing this is the best racing out
there it's not even close the level of a
passing excitement that I've said I
absolutely 100% sold on this sport and
you know what's something really
interesting on their website what it
showed all the muscle groups that you
need to ride one of these bikes and
basically when they open up the throttle
wide open when they find out you it's
you need basically the same amount of
strength you would need to do a pull-up
a hundred and ten percent of your body
weight so let's say I weigh
unfortunately like a you know bucks I
think I'm I think I'm a little less than
180 180s my one time when I'm just like
I got [ __ ] drop some weight let's say
I'm 180 so that would basically mean 190
and about a hundred not like I was gonna
do like a pulldown of 198 pounds which I
could not do and that's basically you
have to be able to handle 110 percent of
your body weight so you don't get blown
off the back of the bike and then when
they slow down and they go into the
turns it's like riding a horse where
it's like you're using your legs holding
on to the bike and then you got to keep
your forearms relaxed because those are
your controls and there's all these
kinds of g-forces obviously I have no
scientific background they have a great
video that I should repost when I reap
I'll repost it that shows all the muscle
groups that you need just to keep that
thing on the bike you just keep yourself
on the bike and what's amazing is once
they get up to speed on the straightaway
which is usually a start/finish line
always seems to be the long straightaway
there's like a 2 or 3 second moment
where they can kind of relax and catch
their breath before they do it again
it's [ __ ] unbelievable and if you've
ever had a chance to drive a car around
a racetrack which I did when I was out
in Las Vegas just going five times
around the track how much your brain
gets thrown around and just how you'd be
like you feel like you flipped the car
at least I didn't just like yeah this is
why I like the count of that cadillac
eldorado I just want to cruise down the
[ __ ] Street I don't be whipping around
corners and [ __ ] anyways check it out
you get a whole new level of respect for
racing because you know for whatever
reason in this country that you really
totally into it or you just feel like do
they just drive around in a circle
[ __ ] stupid yeah so Major League
Baseball's back today today Yankees
first Nationals hopefully Aaron judges
back and he's all healthy so you get to
see what that giant Mickey Mantle's
going to do and then one of the greatest
rivalries
ever going back to Brooklyn at Ebbets
Field on the Polo Grounds in New York
City up in Harlem you got a Brooklyn and
Hallam you got our Dodgers versus the
Giants try to behave yourself fence oh
actually the fans won't be there so
that's a good thing
crazy [ __ ] West Coast fans no one's
gonna get kicked in the head till they
[ __ ] died a few years later you
always got to bring that one up right
absolutely that one's gone went down and
then the next day I think the Red Sox
has to have the Blue Jays or something I
don't know who the [ __ ] they're playing
but I'm gonna watch a little bit of that
and then the NBA the NBA comes back on
July 30th on the 31st my beloved Boston
Celtics play the Milwaukee Bucks and at
some point I guess the NHL is gonna come
back with some round-robin [ __ ] like
the bean pot sort of quick playoff
system we shall see we shall see so
that's what's going on in the sports
world very exciting that the sports are
coming back and I don't I don't know
what else to tell you hopefully the
kovat thinks going down I don't know
because like the rest of you I've been
hemorrhaging cash I have not [ __ ]
work to people in since March ok and
I've built bill I've I've squeezed a
nickel here or there I'll tell you that
but Jesus Christ I mean I don't think I
have a plan to take a whole [ __ ] year
off I'll tell you what's nuts right now
is the price gouging the [ __ ] price
gouging if you want to try to get out
anywhere you know personally I don't
have a [ __ ] problem you know we got a
nice house you know if they dumped all
these [ __ ] money into it
I'm fine staying here but you know I've
been able to run out and go do errands
so my wife's been going crazy you know
when she likes the beach okay she has a
little more pigment than I do so she
loves the beach I'm not into the beach
at all [ __ ] ocean terrifies me and
the sand burns me up so let's say it
burns me up so I'm not into that [ __ ] at
all but like I am into my wife and her
happiness I love her to death so I need
get her out to the ocean so we were just
looking at some you know some just
[ __ ] little [ __ ] little bungalows
he can't [ __ ] believe the money that
they want it's [ __ ] ridiculous we
looked at one just south of Santa
Barbara for like a Friday through leave
Monday morning they wanted $15,000 Oh
Mike that was the easiest go [ __ ]
yourself that was debts go [ __ ] yourself
anytime pandemic no pandemic and you
know remember that guy at the beginning
of all of this [ __ ] who hoarded the
[ __ ] hand sanitizer basically the
only American who took this [ __ ]
seriously so he made the proper
investment and he got [ __ ] [ __ ] on
and he had to dump his crap what about
all of these [ __ ] with oceanfront
property that are now [ __ ] charging
all of this goddamn money I swear to God
all of his [ __ ] [ __ ] that we've been
talking since 9/11 you know support the
troops and you know waved the flag and
all of that it's all lip service what it
really comes down to it it's if you can
[ __ ] somebody you know you're gonna [ __ ]
them that's basically there's no [ __ ]
loyalty in any of this [ __ ] what a [ __ ]
do you get off charging that money well
that's what the market will bear go [ __ ]
yourself
I'm so sick of that [ __ ] that and and
that's how business is done well that's
how business is done you know if you
were new to business that's how business
is done what you have a smile on your
face and the customer's always right
unless they're a [ __ ] you always have to
have a caveat there cuz there are a lot
of concept heir right we give people a
decent portion of food is that how
business is done no business is done
this way all the money comes to me and
I'm gonna [ __ ] rob you blind and then
when you audit me I'll then I'll just
bet hey you know it's how business is
done
hey that's what happened to me so anyway
that was interesting so guess what we're
gonna be staying here
um I'll tell you you know it's expensive
when even your wife goes Jesus Christ
you know because we all know the Broads
there they go with emotion first emotion
first bottom line later okay I just need
[ __ ] hermit crab yeah so that was out
out the [ __ ] window I got a fight so
I'll find some [ __ ] methi part of the
coast
you know zombied [ __ ] lunatic part of
the coast maybe I can get in there for
[ __ ] 11 grand
[ __ ] that anyway
plowing ahead here today you wouldn't
know it by my mood today marks 600 days
no booze what up about up be but up will
600 day 600 days no booze you booze at
my age you lose 600 days you think after
600 days I could just be like hey you
know I would just love to have one cold
ice-cold Budweiser or Miller High Life
that's not what I think I think you know
what that dive bar right there I want to
go in there at about [ __ ] 2:00 in the
afternoon and I want to start and I want
to walk out of there around 7 p.m. I
want to pass out and then wake up around
10 have a little hair of the dog and
then pass up for the night that's what
the [ __ ] I want to do that's what I'm
thinking of doing that's not what I
always did when I was drinking but
that's after 600 days you would think
that I would want to [ __ ] dip my toe
and I don't I do not I want to
cannonball right into the [ __ ] deep
end although a buddy of mine he's been
been mr. chthamalus the the producer of
the Monday morning podcast there's the
empty news just before 8:00 okay he's
been drinking IPAs so I know those are a
little bit heavier just having like one
IPA here or there so I was thinking
maybe I could do that I don't [ __ ]
know but you know something I gotta tell
you this at my age even not boozing it's
hard to keep the [ __ ] weight on off
the last thing I need to do is go back
to that [ __ ] [ __ ] so
I don't know I guess I should be excited
600 days I'm just sad that I can't
[ __ ] drink anymore
being honest I had so much [ __ ] fun I
really had a great time you know but
like I said like I've been saying I
would have saved up some of my fun days
had I known that now I got to go dry for
them like what the final [ __ ] in twenty
five thirty I always say twenty five
thirty trying to be modest but I plan on
making a hundred anyway so that's the
deal
six hundred days no booze I shaved my
beard off you know I got sick of the
whole [ __ ] everybody
during this pandemic has been growing
beards I did a zoom podcast and
everybody on it had a [ __ ] beard and
everybody looks like [ __ ] Tom Hanks
in castaway and I just I just like I
don't want to [ __ ] look like this
anymore so I shaved it off I was
hilarious
my daughter was just like dad why you do
that it's like you know just stab like
something different
she's like wait what why it just kept
asking me why I did it
and so I figured I should get used to it
and then yesterday she said dad wear
your beard and mustache so I don't know
maybe I'll gradually grow it back but
I'm kind of a Jew I think I'm gonna go
[ __ ] clean-shaven for the rest of the
summer I will tell you though oh well
[ __ ] Billy I don't have a [ __ ]
wrinkle on my face I get a little bit
crow's feet
[ __ ] you know the wrinkles you know
and on the forehead but I mean I you
know I moisturized people I did do that
right as much as I I moisturize and I
gotta tell you and I stayed out of the
Sun I got to tell you something as a
borderline albino to be looking as good
as um I look [ __ ] great for 50 - okay
let's let's be honest 52 is not a not a
number you want to look at all right but
if you did have to look at it I look all
right
I think I'm doing okay you know man I'm
trying to stay positive over here me
hmm so yep so I just needed to switch it
up I think that maybe I'll get my wife
to do that she got to switch it up or
something like that to keep it yeah make
it new again do something different so
we don't lose our minds stager a little
parcel of property here but I changed
the drum heads I went with a clear
ambassador head on my my to racked my
one rack Tom on my floor Tom and I gotta
be honest with you it sounds the exact
same as the coated one as far as I know
although it does sound good my drum
teacher Dave Allah taught me this way of
toning or tensioning drums that like you
just guaranteed you're gonna get a
[ __ ] good sound you're gonna get a
round tone you're not gonna get like
where the the top head and the bottom
head are competing with each other and
just getting some [ __ ] [ __ ] sound
it's [ __ ] easy as hell and all it is
is like all of these years you know they
show you the pattern of going around and
around and around and all of that
no one ever stopped to tell you that you
want to feel equal pressure so you kind
of just go by feel whatever the pattern
is that you're using you just go by fear
fear by feel so because what happens is
as you turn those if you just say I'm
gonna do a half turn all the way around
with whatever pattern you're using the
the head is is starting to get seeded on
top of the drum so then what happens is
is to basically have an equal amount of
tension with the opposite one a lot of
times you have to go a little further
because it's starting to sit down and
obviously the whatever the [ __ ] you call
it the thing that you screw in there is
now further away from the whatever the
[ __ ] you call the the rim there Jesus
Christ the lug what happened oh I I
swear to God the older you get the less
words you use and if you don't use the
other words you forget them as the
bearing edged is the rim and then
there's the lug yeah so you just you
just go by feel as you still do the same
pattern you
and you might I'm just saying you don't
definitely have to turn further on the
opposite lug but you just just muscle
memory remember that the how how much
resistance you were getting on one he
just duplicate that as you go around and
you're gonna be pretty goddamn close and
eventually what I want to do is I got to
go back and watch that Benny grab one
because Benny grabber has the sickest
sounding [ __ ] drum kit I've heard
since Steve Gadd back in the day up
close when he had to black those black
Tom heads that like his floor toms were
the best sounding that I had ever heard
and then Benny Greg came along and like
I don't know how the [ __ ] he does it I
mean it sounds like a [ __ ] cup a
couple of bass drums and he has this
whole way of doing it I just don't have
the same drum key he gets his drum key
that L sounds like a rubber stopper on
top that is part of it I got to go back
and watch it God knows I have the time
and I got a couple extra drums that I'm
not using on my kit right now I'm just
playing like a four-piece that's kind of
what I like I like the four-piece but I
gotta get one of my other drums although
again I got a 12 and a 13 to 12 I'll
just keep tuning that up and down and
just using the Benny grep method I just
got to get that same drum key that he
has and I want to get [ __ ] I just
decided like that's what the [ __ ] I'm
gonna do shave the beard off I don't get
really good at tuning up my drums I
already know I can get it for finally
after all of these years thanks to Dave
ela tech and now actually tuned up a
drum kit and it sounds pretty good and
I'd like to get great at it because
becoming great at playing drums just
doesn't seem like that's ever gonna
happen for me maybe I could be a trumped
a dad band drum tech I have no idea but
I've been just everything that I'm
trying to do playing drums I just always
end up like hitting a wall
and I'm learning that it's coming down
to the way I'm sitting the tension I'm
holding in my body and how I'm breathing
and you just want to be like relaxed and
what happens is with me anyways with
playing drums is whatever I'm working on
if I'm playing along to the song it's
really hard to fight off the here it
comes here it comes and you [ __ ]
tense up and especially if there's any
sort of speed involved it's like the
faster you play the more relaxed you
have to be it's [ __ ] wild and for
some reason that's the exact your body
because you're going faster you know
speeding it up you equate speed with
more difficulty which brings anxiety or
whatever just causes you to tense up
it's just it's [ __ ] unbelievable it's
really ridiculous how that works because
I can play that bonham triplet lick at
about 85 bpms but if I'm playing along
to the song I can only play it like it's
75 and of course Bonham plays it at 95
and of course he also did it at [ __ ]
19 and didn't get his first drum kit
until he was 15 you know it's always
things like that where I go yeah Billy
you definitely picked the right Road but
stop ending here I'm gonna be a
professional drummer dream and becoming
a comedian so anywho I'm just gonna get
into that type of [ __ ] and I don't know
I do will tell you one of the great
blessings though is I've been home every
single day of my son's life which has
been [ __ ] awesome and I've just
decided to focus on that and the fact
that motorcycle racing is back baseball
is back the fact that people are finally
buying into wearing these masks I think
this [ __ ] thing's gonna go away and I
just believe just I guess 2020 is just a
wash and I'm already trying to plan
ahead how are we going to do the [ __ ]
holidays you know because we always had
like this big kid Halloween thing party
where people come over with their kids
and they dress him up and
you know a lot of our friends are
obviously in the business of show
business they're really talented people
and some of the creative stuff that they
come up with this woman last year had
her kid come over dressed up as an old
lady had a little walker and put little
cotton balls for her hair and had little
granny glasses on it was the cutest
thing I've ever seen in my life
and every year there's always like you
know somebody that just has like that's
this killer office so that one of those
things that we look forward to you know
and I would make the pumpkin bread and
all of that type of stuff so I don't
know I guess we'll just have to scale it
down but I will tell you this I am still
going all out still making the pumpkin
bread still making the pies still
throwing down for Thanksgiving you got
to do something right anyways but
whatever who do you like the Yankees
first the Nationals I got a record that
game do I have to record the game no
it's coming on this afternoon no
tomorrow's game I go record there yeah
the Red Sox game tomorrow all right let
me do a little bit of reads here
everybody and I'm just gonna keep
advising you guys to stop watching CNN
and Fox News okay they are in the
business of dividing this country and a
divided nation is a weak nation and that
is an issue of national security so
whatever you like the right of the left
red or blue ties or bras whatever the
[ __ ] you're into just stop watching
those [ __ ] [ __ ] I really wish
that their ratings would just absolutely
[ __ ] plummet and that they would be
forced to actually be journalists again
as opposed to the op Edie
[Music]
and all of the [ __ ] [ __ ] that they're
doing and and just scream and fire in a
crowded movie theater that they do it's
just it's the one of the worst [ __ ]
things that's ever happened to this
country we get people a little yelling
at each other
about wearing a masks morning Mass
during a [ __ ] pandemic that's the end
result you know then you got everybody
on the left everything that's ever been
wrong with this country is because of
Donald Trump all right simply safe
everybody
what's the number-one sign of a bad home
security system a ax-wielding murderer
standing at the end of your bed that you
didn't understand well gay a home
security system that's so complicated
you never use it exactly the end result
is that yeah
turned out to be a mouse not a rat it's
a mouse and I got to tell you something
I have a soft spot soft spot soft spot
in my heart for mice I like mice I don't
like him in my house house but I
actually as far as rodents go they're
[ __ ] adorable I love a mouse you know
what I mean in the [ __ ] that they've
gone through through labs and all of
that [ __ ] rats
unfortunately they like they like the
Sharks of rodents in my cell like the
Dolphins you know what I mean
it's funny because a dolphin will help
save you from drowning
everybody looks past the fact that
they've raped a lot of trainers and
sharks just are just you know they're
sharks you know they never used
Invisalign they got sharp teeth they're
all over their [ __ ] mouth and they're
just doing their job they're just doing
their job which is to [ __ ] eat
anything that's sort of weak out there
which human beings are in the ocean I
used to read run away Ralph when I was a
kid I used to read that series a book so
maybe it was just one book I can't
remember and he had a little [ __ ]
motorcycle and he had a little
peanut-shell helmet and all of that
ratatouille with the great Patton Oswalt
wasn't out yet so there wasn't any good
press for rat so I still [ __ ] hate
rats I don't know what to tell you but
anyway simply safe everybody what's the
number one sign of a bad home security
system a home security system that's so
complicated you never use it this is
exactly the type of security system
simply safe has spent a decade fighting
against they believe that simp simple is
safer and it's exactly why simply safe
is the home security for right now when
feeling safe at home has never been more
important yeah I got up a couple buddies
of mine just bought guns I just don't
get like having the gun and then you
always have to have it in some [ __ ]
safe and all of this [ __ ] it's not
readily available then also if you use
the thing you're gonna blow out
your eardrums so for the rest of your
life your ears are ring and because that
[ __ ] [ __ ] came into your house all
right and on all they do is just go to
the gun range and then they just shoot
it and non-moving you know silhouette I
guess you got to go out and you got to
do the pole you know with your handgun
go skeet shooting with your [ __ ]
handgun I don't know I don't know how it
works to be honest with you but my ears
is so shot I'm thinking of maybe getting
a crossbow and just having that thing
[ __ ] loaded you know I don't
understand why are silencers illegal for
somebody who's never you know why cuz
somebody will eventually kill this
spouse and it would just would just be
too goddamn tempting I'll talk about
that me finish this [ __ ] read they
believe that simple is safer and is
exactly why simply safe is the home
security system for right now when
feeling safe at home has never been more
important simply safe was designed to be
easy I can do what you do to use while
protecting your whole home 24/7 order
online with the click of a button open
the box place the sensors plug it in
yeah you're out of your mind during a
pandemic if you're not doing this and
your home is protected around-the-clock
no tech technician or salesperson has to
come and disrupt your house you don't
need to pay any outrageous monthly fees
or sign a two-year contract simply safe
was named best overall home security of
2020 by US News and World Report and
there 24/7 professional monitoring and
emergency dispatch starts at 50 cents a
day head to simply safer calm and get
free shipping and a 60 day money back
guarantee that simply safecom to make
sure they know that our show sent you
alright
yeah dude if you had like a silencer I
just think that it would just be way too
[ __ ] easy you know to take out
somebody that you you you were probably
knew you know with the silencer you have
time to get your story together not
saying it's going to work
you know what I mean I'll tell you like
and it's all yeah you know something
people would be too much at Cowboys if
they had silencers because I'll tell you
right now if I had a [ __ ] little
pistol with the silencer on it and I saw
that [ __ ] little Mountain a mouse if
it was a mouse I'd be like Bernie if it
was a rat I just start [ __ ] shoot you
know yeah there'd be too many
I don't know but silencers are legal in
Florida you know they are legal in
Florida let's look this up dude I've
looked up some of the most [ __ ] up
[ __ ] lately some of my my scans here
scans know what some of my searches
states where silencers are legal all
right here we go currently the 42
[ __ ] states allow private ownership
of suppressors alright let's see we got
the ones that you knew Alabama Arkansas
Arizona
I guess Oh aka is is that Alaska sorry
Alabama Alaska Arizona I'm doing it I
got I can't always do a southern accent
that's my old retired Republican Arizona
Arkansas wait is that Alaska what's what
zebra abbreviations for states can my
computer hear me list of all
abbreviations let's see here Alaska is a
cake okay it is a K all right let's get
back to it I'll try to do the proper
accent for all I can't do okay Alabama
Alaska Arizona Arkansas Connecticut
Colorado Florida Georgia Indiana Idaho
wait if I n is Indiana what's IA Iowa
Kansas Kentucky Louisiana one of my
favorites Louisiana Maine Maryland
[Music]
Minnesota I don't even know I don't know
my [ __ ] mi is Michigan sorry
MD is that in Maryland let's say Maine
Maryland Michigan don't [ __ ] it take the
oh my word for hit Minnesota ms/ms mo is
Missouri right
what is ms mississippi right [ __ ] these
up man I haven't done this in a while
and ease that New England
that's Nebraska Nevada New Hampshire New
Mexico North Carolina North Dakota Ohio
Oklahoma Oregon Pennsylvania they let
people in Philly have silencers oh Jesus
South Carolina South Dakota Tennessee
one of my favorites Texas of course Utah
Vermont Virginia Washington West
Virginia Wisconsin in Wyoming let's make
it easier huh silencers aren't illegal
California Massachusetts New York right
let's see where are they legal oh they
got a nice colored in map here okay so
basically they are legal in every state
except California Illinois that would be
because of LA in Chicago Massachusetts
New York Rhode Island New Jersey and
yeah wait a minute this got in Hawaii
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute what states do
suppressors the eight states that
currently do not allow silencers are
California Delaware Hawaii Illinois
Massachusetts New York New Jersey Rhode
Island and the District of Columbia
basically the brains of the outfit the
smartest people lit and I'm kidding
I just want you guys we all so there you
go who knew who the [ __ ] knew I think
there's just too many people and too
many [ __ ] wise guys in New York New
Jersey area Massachusetts were super
liberal it's funny it's so funny that
Massachusetts is that [ __ ] liberal
while simultaneously you know has a
reputation for being as racist as it is
it all comes down to you know state jobs
I think people want to lean on a shovel
not having that taken away all right
LegalZoom everybody it's a whole new
world out there we're all face we're all
faced with new challenges if you need
legal if you need legal help to overcome
some of yours
that's where Legal Zoom fits in maybe
you've been wondering about the best way
to protect your family or maybe you're
thinking about starting a business but
you don't know the best way to do it
don't let legal questions hold you back
Legal Zoom has been dedicated to helping
you with the right solutions for more
than 19 years if you're looking to
protect your family with the will or a
living trust or you're thinking about
the right way to start a business with
the DBA LLC nonprofit or Mulla Legal
Zoom got you covered
legal zooms got you covered I thought
they were getting all like hip-hop and
cool there Legal Zoom got you covered
legal zooms got you covered it's easy to
get started online and if you need
guidance their network of attorneys can
provide advice to ensure you make the
right choices and since Legal Zoom isn't
a law firm you won't have to leave your
home and you won't be charged by the
hour visit legalzoom.com today today to
take care of some important things you
need to get done that's legalzoom.com
Legal Zoom where life meets legal
alright ok I think that's the podcast
for this day by the way the old movie
I've been watching I watched Robin Hood
1938 starring Errol Flynn and yeah it's
a little bit dated but it's considered
one of the great movies of all time and
I actually watched it it's sort of like
the original Braveheart you know when
everybody still had to do [ __ ] stunts
and all of that [ __ ] I was watching that
I watched the first half hour that I
know I cannot recommend by the way late
night Turner Classic Movies on a Friday
night after 2 o'clock to 2 a.m. they
show like some like cult classics just
crazy [ __ ] and they also show like these
car videos and like police training
videos from way back in the day and this
weekend I watched one on the on the was
it the Chevy Corvair the one that Ralph
Nader tanked and said was the most
unsafe car ever I was watching these
people driving up a [ __ ] stream for
20 miles
showing how awesome the car was
Chevrolet Corvair yeah it was Chevy
Corvair good-looking car too but I had
an engine in the back and all of that I
guess I don't know if he hit something I
guess it was really bad I have no
[ __ ] idea all I know is this is there
was another video that I watched I'll
see if I can get the name of it I got to
tell you dude I don't know if you want
to watch this thing it was like one of
those ones that they stare people about
10 years older than me they stopped
showing it in driver's ed by the time I
had come along and they just wished
they'd used to show to scare the [ __ ]
out of young drivers they would show
footage from fatal accidents dead bodies
and all this [ __ ] and they were showing
the [ __ ] I'm talking people burned up
people like slammed into a tree back
when there was like no crumple zones and
the engine just came through the
firewall you got impaled by the steering
column and just the whole thing was like
an accordion then you like
almost like like toothpaste we're just
sticking out the side you got squeezed
out the side it was it was [ __ ]
disturbing and I know all you guys like
well I got to see that all right
they used to have a mountain a
California these we called look called
red asphalt and this one was back in the
50s when cars were super super [ __ ]
unsafe Jalen always had that great joke
about the dashboard the the all this
[ __ ] that was sticking out of it to
impale you and they would just hose it
off for the [ __ ] next guy all right
let me see here what the [ __ ] was it
called
let me look try to find this for you
highway death videos police 1950s
graphic see what I come up with here it
was like code 39 or something like that
where the [ __ ] I mean it was just
footage of accidents here let me see was
it 39 code 30 or something like that let
me see if I can find this for you signal
30 oh my god signal 30 1950 9 I'm dumb
I'm giving you a nice [ __ ] warning
this [ __ ] video I mean this [ __ ]
video is not something like I didn't
feel right after I [ __ ] watch this
but it also made me want to drive a lot
more careful holy [ __ ] signal 30 check
that out I'm sorry if I ruin your
[ __ ] weekend alright that's it I'll
post that and then I'll post no [ __ ]
that
you got to listen to the podcast to get
that one signal 30 and I'll post the
MotoGP one alright that's it that's the
podcast have a great weekend you can't
keep wearing your masks and don't watch
seeing
and Foxx [ __ ] those guys they're not
Americans they're pieces of [ __ ]
profiting off of all our misery all
right that's it I'll see you hey Bill
burr this is actually an intro before
the intro to the podcast this is not the
official podcast at this point I was on
the road and I recorded the podcast on
Thursday I did it into my iPhone and my
iPhone wasn't synced up to my computer
and I'm too much of a [ __ ] [ __ ] to
be able to figure out how to deal with
that so it's I had to fly back give it
to my tech guy so I just now it's fine I
just want to let you know that that's
what it is because in five seconds
you're gonna hear me talking about hey
it's Thursday look at me doing it all
[ __ ] early all right so that's the
that's the reason for that before you
send me your emails all right go hey
what's going on it's Bill burr it's the
Monday morning podcast from Monday July
16th 2012
recording it this week on my iPhone I'm
on the road so I wasn't gonna bring my
mixer and all that other [ __ ]
got a big week I'm actually recording
this on a Thursday before I do my show
so if something amazing happened like if
somebody very important died or if that
asteroid hit the [ __ ] planet that's
because and I'm not addressing it it's
not like I'm doing some hipster thing
trying to act like I don't notice it's
Thursday here and I'm in Boston right
now the friendly confines I've been
behind enemy lines since 1995 so I'm
back here in Boston and I figured what
better time to do a podcast with a
fellow Boston sports fan Dave Portnoy is
my guest this week till I have a real
show here by the way
he's the creator yeah the creator of
barstoolsports.com which is so big now
that I've heard it's now in New York
Philly well New York's version of
barstool obviously they're not talking
Boston sports but before we get into
this it's it's like you know his his
website is you know all things Boston
and then it just shoots off from there
from political stuff to the smoke show
of the we
right the Hajj pretty much anything that
we feel like talking about so it's we
have the Boston version New York Philly
college version but it's uh it's almost
like a guy gossip site if you want right
that way but your let me ask you this
because you know everybody can get a
bunch of hits and that type of [ __ ] on
on the internet you know but like to
actually make money off of the internet
that's what I want to do all right out
of the gate was to congratulate you that
you actually tried and you know there's
like major movie studios trying to
figure out how to [ __ ] make money on
the internet because everybody like
Pirates they're their movies and all
that type of stuff so congratulations
dude welcome to the world of making
money and not really technically having
a job ya know it's not a bad place to be
it's not a bad place to be and it was a
long grind but we're here now Wow how
long how long has it been since you
started barstools been around for like
seven years start as a newspaper so I
know you see the racks and proper
Bostonian all that crap we were just a
free gambling rag four pages
black-and-white OSI you started off
giving people pics and stuff like that
yeah yeah it was sort of like that I
mean I was like a man I was a degenerate
gambler so I I hated my job nice tried
to move to Vegas get a job well I
thought wait wait wait how bad did the
gambling get were you like one of those
guys like oh it's 5-hour energy on the
way to you on the way of Foxwoods no no
I was never really big Foxwoods guy much
more sports you can't get drove it so
much at Foxwoods because you need the
money in your hands you can go probably
much more with like sports because
they'll give you a credit but I mean I
used to gamble a lot hated my job how
far in did you get like how much you
make in a week and how much did you go I
mean I well this will be all relative
but I mean I I've been down 30 40 grand
before that's a shift on 30 40 grand
yeah are they like knocking on your door
at that point well you know what you
have relationships my guy who I've gone
through my he'll love this part me
talking about but I've been going
through him since college so I in it
gradually you know I got fortunately
don't go through him anymore right yes
any problems right no yeah
I was still music but but you see each
other around the holidays you get to be
such a degenerate and you get to be so
lose like I never win
never I mean I've gambled since I've
been alive I probably collected 2 weeks
and 30 years so it's like I you know I'm
always gonna lose so if I lose it's now
to the point if I lost let's just throw
a number if I lost 20 units I'll only
have to pay 10 I get unbelievable
discounts and it's never knock on your
door you always knows I'm gonna pay like
most of it worked so it's never been
like dude I never had the heart for it a
long time ago in like the late 80s the
Patriots sucked I forget what year but
they were supposed to be good I think it
was 89 and I wasn't you know I'd spent
all my money on season tickets you know
and and they just kept losing so I was
like [ __ ] this I'm gonna I'm gonna win
some money back so they were losing to
everybody and the Buffalo Bills came to
town and this is 89 so it was before
they were the run-and-gun and everybody
know but but but this was the [ __ ]
team but they did and like the bills
always sucked between OJ in the
run-and-gun they just you know they had
a couple decent years so you know I
buried him which was 50 bucks in my life
for something like that I buried them
and I think Miami and they both the
Patriots of Miami and they both didn't
come through when I was down like a
hundred bucks I was making like 175 a
week and that was enough for me I did it
once I think the greatest thing ever
happened me is I didn't win the first
week like did you win the first week and
then oh no most people generally do when
no I just you know I just had the
disease it's like I love doing it I know
luckily for me I haven't done it and
it's all probably actually this is how I
rationalize in my brain I don't think I
want it done barstool if I didn't have
that like gene because there's so much
risk with what we do even now like
concerts concerts arts like stock market
type [ __ ] it's like you know that's how
we'd make a lot of our money we do these
like basically raised for college kids
get those black out exactly so we'll
rent out buildings and you know we're
basically petting on kids buying the
tickets like we're laying out tens of
thousands of dollars before we do it
hoping don't tell the listeners a little
bit about that because I didn't know
about those I knew you did all the
talking this stuff about sports and all
that type of stuff so you host these
things black out
all parties everybody gives you [ __ ]
right that they yeah we get [ __ ] from
everybody
we're like enemy number one of Boston
and lately moving I mean somehow we've
ended up I mean the calls from 2020 we
were on Inside Edition with that thing
who's the guy who's the gay guy with the
short blonde hair good-looking guy
Anderson Cooper Anderson Cooper he they
called I mean it's all about the
blackout parties for even though
everyone's not doing similar stuff but
these are rates I'm gonna take don't
know if he's getting on I'm not trying
to out that guy in the park no I think
he's a no I think you see I don't know
no he's out it he outed himself oh he
did yeah okay say you maybe use a
Thursday excuse no he's you may want to
research it in case you don't have him
not it makes sense he's got great hair
gay guys always have great yeah no my
wife thinks he's the hottest guy but I'm
99% sure that he's said he's gay and if
he has it's such a classic podcast
moment we don't even know now I'm gonna
go with exec it's [ __ ] fact well
there's nothing I got nothing you can
sue me for so it wait allegedly ah who
gives a [ __ ] either my reputation on it
oh yeah no matter what even if he hasn't
said I'm pretty sure he is but I think
you said it but it's your podcast not
mine so I mean what but I think he is
gay um hey everyone have you ever walked
into the post office and said you know
what I don't think I ever want to come
here again not that I hate the postal
industry not that I hate the people who
work here not even that I ate postcards
or something else whatever would it be
great if you could take the post office
and bring it into your own apartment
well fortunately there's a way you can
do it stamps calm everybody basically he
got your post office in your apartment
if you're a fan of this podcast you've
heard this a zillion times this is a
zillion and one anything you can do at
the post office you can do right now
from your desk in your apartment in your
house in your shanty to little town in
Haiti stamps calm you can buy and print
official US postage for any letter or
package using your own computer and
print and unlike the post office stamps
calm never closes so you can get postage
whenever you need 24/7 basically you can
print legal postage and the
a little scale and like I always say you
know you can wear a hat if you want to
but that's not included you get a little
scale you can wait packages you can do
all this in the nude in your own house I
love it I use it I endorse it and that's
it right now use my last name bir b you
are r for this special offer no risk
trial plus a hundred and ten dollar
bonus offer includes a digital scale and
up to fifty five dollars in free postage
don't wait act now go to stamps calm
before you do anything else
click on the radio microphone at the top
of the homepage and type in bir b you
are r that's stamps calm enter bir we're
getting all the advertising out of the
way here we go amazon.com would you like
to help this podcast and help the
Wounded Warrior Project sure we all
would how do we do it bill well you go
to bill bird comm you click on the
podcast page and on the right hand side
you'll see the Amazon link you'll see
the banner I should say and you just
click on that and then go buy something
on Amazon if you want that's saying you
have to and they'll kick a percentage to
me I take 10% of that and I give it to
the Wounded Warrior Project
actually at this point I'm kicking 10%
of all the advertising to that project
because why wouldn't you why wouldn't
you ie an American well there you go
specifically an American from the United
States before anybody gets a little a
little fancy with the geography you know
people in Canada they're American they
all live in North America what about
people in Honduras hey what about your
mother
alright get back to me with that one
alright the last one gamefly.com
everybody do you like to play video
games while you pretend to listen to the
person yours allegedly in love with
wouldnt it be wonderful if you had 8000
games to choose from and a 15 day free
trial 15 days free trial gamefly.com
slash bill berg go on there you got
access to 8000 games play until your
damn thumbs fall off and then you can
say you know what I'm good
I tried all your games I'm good it's
fantastic
here gamer that's the place you want to
go gamefly.com slash bill burr click on
the where they got where they
a little game player I don't want you do
just go there and buy something makes me
look good all right have a nice week I'm
glad we got that cleared I don't
remember now I'm off track whatever
black oh so basically what we do with
the blackouts
I'm gonna guess if you didn't know that
Anderson Cooper wasn't gay that you
don't really know what like EDM music is
either do you you met EDM like dance
music you know only because it was on
the cover of Rolling Stone recently just
that that Danger Mouse not danger bossy
deadmau5 deadmau5 deadmau5 know that I
didn't know was deadmau5 at my [ __ ] he's
a deadmau5 because I was saying deadmau5
my girls gonna I think it's deadmau5
when they use of five is like an S he
where's the mouth said I'm Monica passed
judgment because two years ago I didn't
know what it was but now I like now I'm
in that scene I'm a hot that's what we
do so it's basically as far as I can
tell it's house music with lasers and
lights and [ __ ] bouncing off kids eyes
that's what it is so it's old-school
like just you know kids are doing drugs
[ __ ] up out of their mind and those
are the parties we do now I'm not saying
it well that that's if if Mayor Menino
heard me say that he'd be like hear
knocking on my door but so we do these
parties we don't supply any of the stuff
but the lasers the lights the hardcore
music and there's that element well it's
it's a rave I mean it's a rave it's a
freaking rave that's really what it is
but it's not just us it's what college
kids do now well I actually saw some of
the some of the video of some of the
girls and stuff like that if I was a
younger man that would be the place I
would go whether I like that music or
not and you actually had like some
eventually we will get to sports on this
guys I know you had you had some fallout
though like you did something like on
your website you had some sort of a some
sort of a joke or whatever and they that
a rape joke yeah and then you went on TV
I got to tell you dude that took balls
man like you sticking up for your joke
like that like I would have stuck up for
my joke but I would have done it with a
little more tact I'll have a link to it
on my for podcast listeners she was just
Lisa Guerrero yeah man she came in lisa
krone what was the joke he's been in
Playboy by the way and used to do
weathergirl for the sports for CBS
sports that Lisa Carrera she's gorgeous
yeah well she was but anyways the joke
was look at me I'm getting price no I
listen I I call it as you see I mean I
know she won't look at me but whatever
point is we had a stewardess story in
Europe Australia where a guy got accused
of rape and was acquitted and his
defense was she was where the judge
agreed with the defense she was wearing
skinny jeans and there's no way he could
have gotten the jeans off without her
consent because there were skinny jeans
so that got him off that got him off
so that was my god so our our take on it
and it was the same take as we do with
everything I mean we make fun of
everybody was it came out in the story
that she was a size six and so I said
who cares about the rape side of things
a size sex should never be wearing
skinny jeans you'll be like well that's
that big yeah well for skinny jeans yeah
I think you'd be zero or two for skinny
jeans and I don't like skinny most a fat
girl you're saying in skinny jeans
that's what I was saying the problem
though they were like building maybe
that's why she the key couldn't get him
up
exactly and that's how he got off and
then I took a step further said who
cares about that you actually if you're
going to wear skinny jeans you probably
deserve to be raped anyway also is
actually a fat joke yeah that's exactly
what absolutely a fats exactly what a
Wow oh I get it so you go so Sony but
Dave goes on this show you'll see in the
clip this girl goes right at you was
just like you know you think rape jokes
are funny and you're something you were
like somehow she was saying you think
that joke is funny and you're like yes I
do and then she then she tried to cook
you she tried to spin it and be like oh
so you find rape funny you're like now I
don't but I did she goes well then I
don't think you understand how offensive
that joke is and then you're like well
evidently I don't and I totally got what
you was saying you was like at least
what I think he was saying well you're
basically saying like like I would
equate it to like seeing an old lady
fall down a flight of stairs in real
life not [ __ ] funny horrific okay in
a Will Ferrell movie real Larry right
because because it's so horrific right
alright so you actually did like a
roundabout
like fat like sort of a fashion joke you
saw making be like going like that's
basically ladies you know if you're a
size six don't try to show him your fat
ass into a rut but you by no means for
condoning condoning right and that's
what everyone's twisted on us in but it
was funny though but you didn't even
explain it to her you just you just
answered her questions and didn't try to
enlighten her at all and like that's
when I watched the clip I was just like
Jesus crying cuz I would have been like
look the joke was about this and then I
would have backed out saying you know
it's not my problem if people don't get
my jokes that's the way I would have
handled it you just were like you you
were like [ __ ] Oliver North it's like
man you know what it came across and
here's the weird thing a lot of people
think that clip made me look like an
[ __ ] whenever people being like [ __ ]
you I would think that would you like
will think that you're a piece of [ __ ]
right exactly like this this [ __ ] uh
you know my mother-in-law is sitting
watching you know Channel four it's like
watching Sun and lost condones rape like
what what's going on but the thing about
it what you just said that they probably
an Inside Edition showed thirty seconds
of me talking I was in there for an hour
and a half and I mean at one point I
thought we were gonna fight each other
dude I gotta tell you that when you're
getting interviewed the longer it goes
that's like the first 48 where at some
point in the interview you have to be
like am I being charged with anything
because if not I'm gonna leave or if I
am I want a lawyer but the longer you
talk that's the same thing doing like
stand-up specials like I remember back
in the day the first time I got a I got
a half-hour on Comedy Central
they were like you know it's you know
it's gonna be 22 minutes because they
have they have eight minutes of
commercials and a half hours so they
wanted us to they were like bare minimum
we need at least 28 minutes so I did 28
minutes on the nose other guys would go
over because the way I looked at it is I
have no power over how they're going to
edit this this is us so I'm gonna give
them a little extra footage as I can and
what ended up happening was they took a
whole joke they just took a whole bit
out I love the bit but I only lost there
was only one thing to be upset about so
I think when you get into those those
inner
like further down the line you should
just be like you know it takes him an
hour and a half to ask you about a
[ __ ] rave and one joke and we're all
over the map and we're dumb idiots I
mean they came to our office through
this camera crew and we're like serve
them tea crumpets be like oh like crack
a joke thing to our buddies with these
people that's one of the first things
you learn does not your friend oh no but
we were we were rolling out the red
carpet like I thought they were friendly
as hell super nice oh yeah great what
you're doing with your website this
really must be great you know yeah
always like meeting new people who are
doing things and then but the second
that interview will end it I knew I knew
this she's gonna make I mean there was I
an I met the camera guy who also did a
20/20 thing that we just did and even he
says like it was one of the more
contentious interviews in it they're
built to be contentious because it was
it was that exchange that type of
tension the whole time with this lady
out the second you sat down you felt she
already I mean we said stuff like she's
I mean I get the exchange we had there
were some exchanges where it was like
she's like well I'm a FEMINIST like well
I saw you naked in Playboy so I don't
think the fact you know they think
you're a feminist and it was that type
of exchange hired is it and what are
they gonna release this on DVD and I the
library hey I would pay five grand cash
for the full interview I actually think
it would make me look right because they
cut up like what you're talking about
she didn't have any of the back contents
I asked her a hundred times like did you
read the blog you're just saying I
condone rape do you even know what it's
about
she couldn't answer it you know she
asked me do I actually think at the end
of the day to use that overly z'd
expression that they love having a guest
like you because at the end I'm gonna
use it again the end of the day they
want people to watch and if they have an
interview like you yeah I think there's
that weird push-pull thing where they're
acting like they're completely outraged
but they're totally psyched that you're
being what they think is an [ __ ]
right and I'm an easy target and I'm
probably somewhat like you and Danny was
sitting there on a tank top well that
that's my that's my army gear like if
brands I'm wearing now but if I show up
to a professional interview in a purple
tank-top similar to this it's a little
more outrageous than when I wear that
means I know you
like me across I'm gonna try to make up
a not a mockery but I it's like my
methyl I know I'm about to meet be made
into an [ __ ] so you like that if
you're gonna try and screw me I'm not
putting on a suit and tie right exactly
I'm not going to try I already know you
maybe look like a jerk that's actually
jerking hilarious that's you you dret
you know what they say as a comedian
you're supposed to dress to the level of
the room you know what I mean like if
you're gonna do like you know some a
room you don't come in there dressed
like a bum and then you know if you're
doing some hellhole you can dress it
down but I always feel like you know you
you know you at least wanna in a hell
room you have some sort of moat between
you and the animals so if you have some
sort of amun showbusiness shiny shirt
like I don't know the whole backstory of
that but all I know when I watched that
I was just like you know that's a lot of
comedian friends of mine Opie and
Anthony show I should send him that clip
like if they haven't seen it like I
think that they would get a kick out I'm
not saying they condone it one way the
other because I'm not trying to get
anybody to dragged in on the ship but
just the two the way you did that and
you there was no like you didn't I cuz I
like I said I would have tried to
explain in a joke I didn't like she
[ __ ] don't face them right back it
was it was real it was funny so you can
I'm gonna see my face actually and when
i rewatch it like I almost grind my
teeth like I knew it was coming
it was like I was gearing up to alright
don't back down right here just go right
back at her well it's gonna be
interesting as you do more and more of
those interviews and I'll be looking now
for the tank top yeah he's got an eyes
on rod he kind of likes this guy may be
the thing so yeah well now that we're I
don't come even like like we haven't
really even talked sports I got to tell
you that the most depressing thing that
I've heard as a Boston sports fan is
like I was excited that Dwight Howard
was possibly gonna go to Brooklyn and my
whole thing is anybody but the [ __ ]
Lakers like because I just feel like
they are better at the free agency game
and they got they have the city that the
dudes want to play in all right they got
better weather they got so we got
basically we have
humidity we have the winter and we have
racists la has better weather celebrity
ass and racist you know because they
always try to act like all the races are
in Boston like you know all you got to
do is just see the LAPD's greatest hits
and you can kind of go through line but
I mean out here it really is like
[ __ ] that that's why it made me
cringe like when I when I watch the
Bruins lose that overtime goal and those
[ __ ] wrote that meathead [ __ ] on
Twitter yeah and I'm like do you realize
that's actually affecting the Celtics
ability right probably yeah could you
keep those a big story yes protal I
think I but I honestly with that [ __ ] I
think I think maybe you're la-la-land by
list because I don't even care about the
Lakers I'm so the heat right now or like
the the gist my expansion franchise
titles I would have rather the Heat
if the Lakers we like this way Lakers
heat in the finals this past year I
route 100% to the Lakers not even a
question in my mind that's how much I
eat Miami I think that's a general
consensus how are you 35 do you remember
Laker Celtics in the 80s no I remember
that let go of that yeah no I haven't
let go of it I haven't let go of it
because it was even there when we had
the Lakers 2009 I know that's one
thousand nine when they called [ __ ]
12 fouls on us on five million oh I know
I know listen I was there I I know but
then I got a Red Bull Ray Allen thing
now - its LeBron I they're my least
favorite my least favorite human on
earth in the heat are right now my least
favorite team on earth so you still hate
LeBron just spicing what I just I hate
everything about just the fact they won
but well it's fascinating this is really
[ __ ] hard for me to talk about now
because he won so it steals a lot of the
[ __ ] that I had going
but before you're gonna know it's all
the reason I hated him more like he's
never won but he's been called his whole
life I hate how he charged his [ __ ]
20 grand to go to his birthday party you
know I hate how he twit something wait
did he send you like an invite and then
oh I read about it though speed on the
internet but all the [ __ ] he does I mean
it just it
everything about him drives me berserk
now granted the fact that I used to
choke in the clutch and all that [ __ ] I
mean it's hard to talk about look you
know you just you literally as you were
telling me that he was unwinding a
[ __ ] paper clip would take something
you gotta let that [ __ ] go it's tough
what not really what about the rail and
older how old are you I'm 44
alright so you got me by a little bit I
got you by a lot too you learn a lot in
the next nine years where you know it is
there something about hitting 40 or
you're coming down the backstretch and
you're like dude if I'm lucky
um this is midlife you know that's
[ __ ] 40 40s 80 right 44 and 40 488
the way I drink forget about it it's
over
so there's something where you just kind
of get to a point of like am I gonna be
this angry I'm not saying you're angry
but like I'm I am I gonna be like this
is there's a certain point I won't let
it go to what but I've gone to I hated
LeBron nobody has cornered me on LeBron
I haven't talked about at all
since he want I used to talk about him
every dev just pretend it didn't exist
after they won but then you brought him
up in the LA thing I'm saying if I lived
in LA I'm sure I would hate the Lakers
more because you're from here and you're
out with all those people but now that
that there might be some truth but I
think I think the general consensus
right now for people living around here
is is the heat and then like I said Ray
Allen going there just makes it a
million times worse well I look at Ray
Allen like look we brought him here to
do a job he did it okay the guy who's
total class act and in the end he saw
the other shoe was gonna drop I felt and
he didn't want to go out like that and
it I don't know that I liked what they
offered them yo-yo you've been soft
you've been softened up I think by the
LA Sun other foot other foot drop how I
just look I think it's one of those
things where you you feel like someone
is slowly breaking up with you and you
just say you know what rather than go
through another two years of this [ __ ]
I'm gonna leave I I did my thing here I
just you know what it is the thing about
athletes is you always see that [ __ ]
that they do but the owners for the most
part the [ __ ] that goes behind the
scenes those guys are faceless you don't
like the bankers no I I'm at as I am
about the [ __ ] bankers I can't put
one face on anybody of who the [ __ ] did
this to the Sakana
me and I feel a lot of times that like
like guys that did just you know you
just you're up you're out there hanging
out to dry
I Ray Allen it was Ray Allen nothing but
a class act in Boston right up till he
left yet okay yeah so I look at it like
there has to be a [ __ ] reason why he
did that
no I yeah mom comes to the game
wholesome guy not a selfish guy a font
Wow no I think he is a little bit of a
selfish guy I think that I will learn it
well I think the reasons they're saying
in comeback is he was insulted by how
hard they went after kg but not him he
was insulted that they weren't building
the offense a little bit more around him
I mean selfish
I don't think he said that he didn't use
those words insulted he just said I felt
there was a feeling might not what's
going through his the Boston sports
blender and by the time it comes out the
other [ __ ] side is really like he
said [ __ ] thoughts all right but no he
said in the thing like my heart's always
in Basel I don't care what you [ __ ]
do how many teams are in the NBA 26 I
don't know how that's 30 30 yeah you
pick the one that you can't go to you
couldn't just picked another one
like that's dude I don't look there are
[ __ ] expansion franchise I don't even
dignify the heat as like I gotta Bend of
Miami dude yeah but I mean LeBrock that
he went down I don't care about the
thing you think the humanity's bad here
and then you got [ __ ] hurricanes and
then half the [ __ ] cities you're
gonna get into a goddamn [ __ ]
gunfight if you go to it and then then
you go out to Miami Beach where all
these rich guys are and it's all these
creepy [ __ ] guys in 60 60 years old
dressed head-to-toe in linen with
19-year old chicks how does that broad
in that show talking about that I don't
care about I don't think she was I don't
care about the fans it's all abroad I
[ __ ] hate LeBron I don't want him to
win the fact he's going there I hate the
big three I hate I hate bastard I hate
how they complain about everything every
of it like that pacer series all they
did was say the Pacers taking cheap
shots person and they were mugging the
Pacers in the middle it
we have any other talk about this that's
what I think the NBA is fixed oh so do I
talk for longest time I said they were
fixing then they [ __ ] came out I
sound like Paul burr see right now dude
I called it the [ __ ] you know they
end up having like a mobbed-up ref like
it at the very least a thing that I can
say is like they it is an unbelievably
inconsistent
the officiating game like you ever
watching a baseball game and like the
strike zone is like what the [ __ ] right
but it's what the [ __ ] the whole the
whole game okay so by the time you get
up second time maybe third time you kind
of got okay this guy's calling him
really [ __ ] low or he's calling that
outside thing I don't know what it's the
way he's standing but it's consistent
like when I became convinced that it was
fixed I went to the Celtics Utah game
the one where Garnett twisted his knee
and that stuff is needed for that season
and I was watching the game and I swear
to God watch that tape there are moments
where you can literally take somebody's
head off no call and then like five
minutes later you even look at a guy
there's a foul and to that me that's you
pullin on the reins letting it go up
onto a chip that is that is totally yeah
that's shaving points yeah blue chips to
me yeah and I mean obviously Celtic
teeth not to keep Harvard not but to
call didn't call and Rondo I mean really
changed the whole series at the end of
Game two oh and then Wade went down the
cup I mean there was a dunk was it I
mean it went from Celtics with 45
seconds or it have been up to
two down two with 45 seconds set the
defense bad memories bad memories the
whole thing like I said I walked it out
of my mind
I just got it look I'm not worried about
the Miami Heat
and their to I hope like is I just don't
want the lake who's first of all the
Lakers kind of be a a championship as as
its you're worried about like the portal
franchise record you know and you know
what it really is dude is I sit in LA
and there's the sports show it is the
worst [ __ ] sport show on TV and
always comes on after the Lakers games
like just when I was like in New York
they always watch the Yankees root
against them and I watch the Lakers I
root against the Lakers and at the end
of the [ __ ] Lakers game this is show
it's Michael Cooper what's-his-face
Reggie Miller's sister Cheryl and this
this asian dude and it is the worst
[ __ ] sports show they're trying to be
like edgy like that when the Celtics got
knocked out by the heat Michael Cooper
came on he had these yellows giant silly
sunglasses yeah yeah yeah giant out of
the clock he had these giant green ones
on he's like I'm wearing these and I'm
taking him off to show that the Celtics
season is over and some stupid stuff
like that and like I would love to tell
that guy one day it's like this is gonna
break your heart Michael I know you
think that you were part of the Celtics
Lakers rivalry but no Boston fan has
nightmares about Michael Cooper they
have nightmares about worthy magic
Kareem those gave us nightmares in the
80s but all when I think I'm Michael
Cooper I think of a guy he didn't suck
but he was on sucks sucks this sucks oh
it sucks
that's all I think of Michael Cooper I
think of a guy who thought for half a
second he could block dr. J and that
dunk he was like I can do it oh no I
can't and he got dunked on so I think
maybe that's what it is
that's why my hatred being you you're so
ridiculous and then toned down because
it's where you live yeah and I go into
sports bars and New York wasn't as bad
because they could actually talk the
game after they gave you [ __ ]
la is really bad because it never gets
beyond like you know Celtics are [ __ ]
you guys suck go Lakers
MVP like it never goes into actually
talk in the game where like with Yankee
fans those guys to talk baseball I'll
give that up too they know the game they
can talk it and I just it drives me
[ __ ] yeah I'm sorry you must be
interrupting you know just you know you
go ahead and take you got Lakers you
that you got LA like in there
in your brain I don't think I think if
you polled people around here right now
nine out of ten let's if you could
that's really interesting enough so the
way to ask the question I guess is if
the heat played the Lakers in the finals
this past year who would you root for we
put it on the block it was almost
universal Heat I mean Lakers people want
the Lakers you know why because Kobe
already had his titles these there's
nothing when a guy wins is first like
when Peyton Manning won his first like
once you win one you can't ever take it
back nobody you know what you don't hate
LeBron no I don't he didn't he didn't
say ooh maybe I'm gonna come to Boston
he didn't the guy look I think the guy
like he had he had something that he had
to get over he had to get over taking
the shot at the end end to the end of
the game and I felt during the Celtics
series he took that shot at the end of
regulation and like gained five or six I
gained two sexy destroyed this and Game
five I forget what game was he took it
and he missed
my buddy goes see [ __ ] units by a mile
yeah yeah whatever I thought he climbed
it off the ring but my thing is he had
the balls to test like a breakthrough
you got it and you know we didn't go in
but he did it and then for the rest of
it you know I mean a championship run
the guy didn't I can't believe his
little brawn podcast buddy I mean that's
did you tell me he'd heal on the back
side he had the balls to take the last
shot when people are saying he's the
best player in like the history of
basketball I'm not saying I a lot of
people say that I mean they compared
them to Jordan you didn't say but you
said he had the balls well when I watch
ESPN I don't listen to what they say
like they're there their deal all that
their deal is to sell the game yeah so
they're all gonna go skip bayless and
just say Tom MVP say whatever yeah I'm
not saying he's not one of the greats
all that [ __ ] bother me three-time MVP
before do you want anything but now we
want any even what do they win I mean
what did they win with Cleveland they
went to the finals dude who care what
they guess though do you think a
Cleveland thing can't even give him
credit for going to the [ __ ] finals
and I'd like to walk into Cleveland any
fan say would you are you glad LeBron
James ever played for you [ __ ] no none
of that wanting that's case yeah because
he left on his home town treat him like
dirt he's the Antichrist though he isn't
he's I don't look I think he got really
bad advice some idiot agent goes you
know be a great idea is if you make
cities beg for you and then sit and talk
about it for a [ __ ] like not even a
half hour an hour whoever I think was
like that the guy who interviewed him I
was like his idea whoever the [ __ ] was
around him should have got fired
there's so many stories they didn't see
that with him being just an ass well
until I I got to hang out with somebody
and see them being asked before I sign
off on that but uh alright let me ask
you this going around is another thing
the Patriots with Bob Kraft that's our
video with that that was your we broke
that video you broke that video correct
yeah that was sent to us well I haven't
revealed how that was sent to us a lot
of people vast but the person who sent
it a snot anyways yeah we got that video
we got that um we broke it the night
before in the morning
so ah like I was actually how do you
feel not indeed you guy you guys big
enough at this point where people like
sports places and stuff are coming to
your sites like like looking at it yeah
you know in our world and blogging world
there's maybe like there's a handful of
sites that kind of all in our range so
something gets posted in one of ours
it's it it will go everywhere is it
around
yeah because enough of the bigger sites
lined up with it and then I'll I mean
like Channel seven interviewed me about
it yesterday they came over and we got
credit you know just like anything I'm
sure with jokes even you know it come to
free-for-all for people trying to get
how long did it take you to go from that
this is how interview to I go all over
the [ __ ] place so let's go back to
that new speed you were handing out that
was a newspaper if yes how long did it
take you and and I wanted to take you to
go from that to actually seeing like
some sort of like movement like this
could actually start going yeah you know
it was one of those things we did the
newspaper for about three years before
the website then the website came and it
was in you won't be a see on the podcast
but it's like a slight slope I always
looked at it like it was you know that
times are it's like very close to make
him not you know having to shut down
even took a job because it was a
full-time job but I took another work
and no money yeah yeah exactly so the
internet yeah if I have to take another
one I lasted like one day because I just
couldn't do it
but it was always a slowly rape joke
your work tank top yeah exactly that
like who is this [ __ ] guy um so it
was always a slight growth and then just
in my heart it was like it always felt
like it was growing and then I don't
know what happened people asked him had
all the time like when did you realize
you kind of were over the hump and and I
think the number one thing that happened
that I start realizing the more I go out
Boston people that I hate press what's
going on
you know that's my nickname on that on
the hint on the thing and that's when it
was a huh maybe you know it's starting
to work and it it just kind of continued
and we've always as in terms of making
money on the internet I mean we've
always been good at we're so small I
think it's tough it's not just
advertising I'll try [ __ ] anything
like it and we'll be aggressive and rest
to go different areas so like the
concert thing isn't really an internet
thing well is that the riskiest thing
you'd say that you've done yeah probably
other than starting it like we invested
a decent amount to start it just to
pilot those newsracks that you put in
the street and to pay for the printing
of the paper but you know I had a sales
background so I called up all the
casinos and offshore so I get you ever
like PartyPoker
it's one of the big online poker places
like when you see it on ESPN all the
guys are wearing either party poker
focus stars like we met with those guys
in Vegas I meant a couple Indian guys
they just built like a friggin computer
program for it so we were in with them
in the beginning and we had enough money
to last like a year or two and then I
just kind of people are always like I
like the quirky [ __ ] like I never
intended to be a writer or a character
on the blog it just kind of just kind of
developed which I think when people ask
me I think that's why it's kind of
successful because there was no plan to
it right necessarily it was like my
podcast I don't know no plan I just
started doing them and then all of a
sudden it just it just sort of you find
your way with it but I at least I had
like stand-up to fall back on so during
those two years the ups and downs of it
will you have in like those nights with
like your thoughts awakened you up like
what the [ __ ] am i doing I still have
those thoughts yeah I mean I still have
those thoughts we did a tour last year
with this guy Mike Posner who he's
writing like Bieber songs now so he's
doing well but I [ __ ] hate him like
poison I mean no one was coming to see
his shows we invested so much in it I
thought I thought we're gonna what how
many promoters are saying that about me
read any [ __ ] tickets that's how the
promoter [ __ ] feels that's how I felt
and it's like I want to [ __ ] I always
make it right guy I always try and I
always make it if ever I'm doing good
right now you know it took me 20 [ __ ]
years but back in the day you know I
always if I ever had any sort of
guarantee you remember like Michael
Jackson did with the Sullivan family up
when that [ __ ] he made a reason they
lost the Patriots yeah I mean is really
the City of Foxborough worried that this
little [ __ ]
80 pound man was gonna somehow come
there and scare of you buddy so the
Foxboro canceled the concert and then
well my
like well you're supposed to pay me
whether i perform or not and then the
Sullivan family who owned the Patriots
back in the 80s had to end up selling
and they sold to that Norelco today well
they sponsored the whole [ __ ] tort
not just here they had the whole Michael
Jackson tour which is a debacle like I
remember reading the finances one of our
writers Jerry Thorton wrote he's best
patriot writer in the city he's awesome
and he wrote a great piece on that whole
thing but yeah the promotor thing
promoters I mean that's a tough racket
like we the thing that we switch with
our black we used to have to pay the
talent and now we don't like we just use
kind of our name the barstool and these
kids are just ready to party so that
takes a huge risk but deal not only that
dealing with some of these guys like I
do not to name any name no name any
names but give me a bad story and some
some artist comes in I mean it's got
well I already named names but uh you
don't seem to have a problem like I
usually try to I love prom name Aeneas I
don't I feel like we're pretty straight
with everybody and people [ __ ] trash
us if they want him but I won't trash
anybody who doesn't deserve to be
trashed the only reason I said him he
does it well we have this letter date is
okay so he goes on it's not like he's
not trying to sell tickets he must have
gone above and beyond no he didn't he
wasn't by tweeting about the concerts
helping to promote it
oh yeah well then yeah go [ __ ] yourself
it's like we're losing you know close to
six figures and you're telling me in the
green room you want like [ __ ] prime
ribbon [ __ ] it's like I'm losing my
shirt
and want a hundred green towels it's
like you know what [ __ ] yeah go go
buy something
yeah have a slice of pizza and call it a
day I'm getting murdered here so it's
[ __ ] like that but do you know as a
performer you know you know black back
in the day you know going in whether you
sold tickets cuz ASA try and she'll I
did this [ __ ] it was the early days
of MySpace and they would just slamming
tours together because of like the Dane
Cook thing everyone was watching going
oh my god he blew up on MySpace and they
just thought it was a when I began can
you not say that on your do you think
he's funny yeah you did [ __ ] great
and then he really intensity takes a
bita ain't took yeah he took it an
unnecessary [ __ ] beating but it just
it's just it's part of unfortunately
going into the public eye you know
everybody at some point is gonna get
beat down you know it all just depends
you could just take [ __ ] you know one
shot a month to the jaw for your entire
career it's still a shot to the family
it happens all the [ __ ] time people
send me I try not to read emails but I
have to read them because I got to keep
up on this stuff but like people you
know if you're in the wrong mood you
know I'd be defenses up they can trash
you but yeah he had a whole other
[ __ ] level yeah dude I'm like I mean
yeah you have strong boss and straight
street credibility like are our readers
in there [ __ ] in this moment though
dude after this they'll probably like
that [ __ ] douche support and LeBron
[ __ ] him I'll never go to another one of
his shows it's like it's it's not
something that you can you can you can
really control so but like back in the
day when I when I would go to do like
those so they try to try to put together
this myspace torn in and this is the
whole tour it was just like well you got
10,000 friends he has 15 and you got 8
so together that's like 30 something we
can go play 2,000 see theaters like that
was the the thought process and there
was no link between the no through line
like you know when they putted you try
to package it's like you put like a
[ __ ] bluegrass guy with his with a
dead little bit yeah there was no
through line so we would show up some of
the venues we did ok and the ones that
we didn't we would walk in nobody would
say hello to us they'd be like one
[ __ ] bottle of Snapple in the back
and you'd look out and there'd be a
bunch of people out there and they're
like this is paper they papered the room
which to people outside the business
that means they gave it away they just
they gave away free tickets to try to
get people to come in there and drink so
they can make some of their money back
and those are the nights you even meet
the [ __ ] promoter if you do it's for
like two seconds so we had a story all
right we did a concert and again this is
the same portal again [ __ ] a
bloodbath
and one of the acts one of the apps that
show up and we're in the back room and
the guy his tour manager comes in and
says they said the main guy won't it go
on stage unless I gave him four grand
cash on the spot on the [ __ ] spot you
know what why would you do that and
exactly that
that's the stuff that I actually made a
video coming home from that because I
was so mad like I just took the flip
cams then this guy hadn't wasn't even
selling tickets no that's the thing we
would let me ask you this what if he was
selling even if he sold the place out
you make an office up you dick I would
do if you're selling out I will treat
you and I'll still treat you good even
if you aren't but I expect some
concession on the other end at what
point do you know like would you say
let's say a two thousand seater how far
before the gig do you know you're taking
a bath do you like this this
[ __ ] got some people have a lot
of walk-up traffic like we thought we
haven't typically occasionally we do you
know we've done now enough of these
where we've been to the same places so
if we've been a House of Blues Boston
and we do a show how it sells there is
pretty indicated of you know of how it
will do across so it's like if we [ __ ]
up an in sell anything at Lupo's which
is 1900 in Providence
then I know we're dead let me ask you
what a managers say when you call up
that client hasn't sold any tickets yet
the client still wants the money what do
they say to you do they have a go I know
he's out of his [ __ ] mind but they
have a tap out they don't know then not
not to me they haven't an agency we
don't just dealing with stuff that we
never dealt with and you know I almost
like the interview like I talk to agents
like oh yeah how much like we don't
negotiate I trust you you trust me and
they would just take me and with like a
big club like that old game point for
all right for whatever that system was
and it bashed me over the head with it
so you know I I'm jaded I'm tough to
deal with now for those people because
it's like I'm so I'm so on edge and just
ready to snap on people so I almost need
a buffer zone I almost need a buffer
zone I know that we could ever have
talent anymore because it's it just it
was it drove me nuts
and being an agent sucks to you go like
just constantly be you know kissing
right now what did the scope of you get
you have your website you have this this
blackout tour that you're doing
I don't know if we even like talk to
people
about barstoolsports.com and it's just
it's like what no I said we have all
talked about it that's funny you did no
what do they say no no no no no I'm
saying on this podcast we haven't talked
about it at all and just for you know
people who are new to this because it
seems to me that you know the fact that
you're in Boston then New York then
Philly and now soon to be in Chicago
that eventually you're gonna have one in
all yeah we'd like to you know our
hardest thing in which I underestimated
when I started this thing is it's really
hard for us to find the people the the
people I like the writing it's I like
we've been lucky I should say lucky can
people send you jest I always want we're
always looking for where is that because
I know like it's a blood I talked sports
a lot so I have a lot of sports fans and
I got to tell you man people send me
some stuff and I get some funny emails
and like people send me questions and
[ __ ] and like like that there's some
really funny people out there so like
tips at barstoolsports.com just that
they want to write all we asked it for
samples CIPS yep like I'm not gonna sit
there a lot of people we get a lot of
this like hire me I'm great like I'm not
even a reply to that but if you are
serious just send like look at her site
for a minute be like this is how they
write and send us a sample of what you
think would work that's good I will 100%
get back to you we're always looking for
writers always looking for new season I
mean I was looking for Chicago for three
years before we finally found a guy I
thought could do it and it's just one
guy you start with like a half-dozen no
we start with a half-dozen I wish we are
as one guy basically runs per city so
you their job requirements really to
post a new blog which is like I don't
know a paragraph or two current events
type thing every four nine o'clock in
the morning to basically 5:00 at night I
mean it's a grind beats a real job but
it's a lot of writing oh you have to
come up with a paragraph of funny [ __ ]
it's basically I mean we're like
carnival so it's will you scour the
internet looking for weird [ __ ] whether
it be sports or just you know I'm trying
to think of a which one of your favorite
weird stories that you guys kind of I
mean we have so many weird ones like
what's up what's the latest one that you
guys today even then rent them I don't
like they banned American flags and rent
them
because somebody complained that there
were too many American flags on the 4th
of July so they banned them totally can
you do it yeah America I guess I guess
so I mean that's a pretty weird story
right so what now what if I have a
Taliban flag in it there's nothing in
there so you can have a bunch of those
[ __ ] home saying that it was that I
should clarify it was the Weymouth
housing authority so it was like in I
guess the the subsidized housing but I
mean I could go look at this thing
there's so many I mean I know there was
a story about the chick with the the
biggest tits in the history of the world
they were just huge black along these
saggy tits to the ground I mean there's
literally that's that the beauty of the
Internet is whenever you think you've
run out of weird stuff there's there's
always more is always gonna be something
else well I'll give you an example of I
answer questions every week you why
don't you want to like people actually
do some [ __ ] reason like ask me
advice I don't know why I like I can't
I'm not good at reading out loud I'm a
[ __ ] but for some reason they they ask
me stories so this says girl with
interesting past all right so I'm going
to need your expert advice on something
I'm an expert evidently because I have a
podcast I really should start doing like
some sort of disclaimer before I do
these before something fries and sue me
okay recently I moved back home after
college and started seeing a girl who
went to my high school but who I never
really talked to things were going great
she's really funny for a broad pretty
cute not to mention has a heightened she
mentioned has as heightened of a sex
drive as I do well maybe that's where
the problem lives so I was telling my
high school buddies how I started seeing
this girl and thought she was the bee's
knees he just lost a range um that's
when one of my pals said wait you know
me and Steve and another childhood
friend of mine smoked a bowl and Eiffel
Tower towered her in the back of a
minivan a couple years ago this is like
one of these Dirty Sanchez thinks Eiffel
Tower I don't know what an Eiffel tell
yeah let me try to guess let's see the
Eiffel Tower it's when you you you build
an Eiffel Tower with an erector set and
you stick it in her ass while you
we're a beret whoa it's like you make
two dudes making the Eiffel Tower this
way she's in the middle oh okay that's
right I think I've heard that one is
that more like the London Bridge then
maybe that the Eiffel Tower okay anyway
so now I have an issue the girl so
basically these two guys they smoked a
joint they football and they [ __ ] two
on wonder if thank God you were here
because he said that like I [ __ ] knew
urban dictionary whenever when it went
in doubt and I'm one of those guys the
internet scares me
so now I have an issue the girls great
but knowing two of my close childhood
friends once penetrated her at the same
time kind of puts a damper on things he
says pretty gay which I kind of have to
go along with I've never understood the
two guys with one girl oh well I yeah no
I I don't know about that like that's
sort of like they wouldn't like if you
cross swords I think then you become gay
I don't think you can become gay but I
think that you're easing agent to being
gay yeah no I'm just saying this way I
look like okay I'm gonna hook up with a
girl the only thing they could enhance
that is either another girl or like I
don't know [ __ ] Goodfellas playing in
the back of pickup - no I leave in that
I don't want to hear Joe Pesci's voices
I'm [ __ ] so to add another all you did
was add another dick you don't think
it's either it's either gay or it's like
you're just
it doesn't make you so heterosexual that
you could just [ __ ] high drive no I'm
firmly I've said that I'm not able to
see my buddy one face yeah no I really
thought I don't want it to two on one
guy but this guy's question is this
question whether he's gonna dump this
girl I think I think that's where we're
going here what should i do should I cut
off cold turkey should I bring it up
should I be the better person say AB
[ __ ] it who cares I'm no Puritan thanks
Bill love your podcasts all right first
of all this girl must be [ __ ] the
[ __ ] out of this guy that he's even
asking this question or he's brutally
ugly something something going on it I
like okay I think you already answered
the question should you break up with
this girl look the honest thing is is if
you don't give a [ __ ] and you actually
like this girl then I stay what there
personally just every
I would go to kiss oh just picture you
know [ __ ] two of my friends
high-fiving over I do like the old Jose
Canseco the forearm smash this there's
no [ __ ] way
no that's one of the all-time no
brainers in the history of earth that
would be a deal-breaker either gay guy
wrote in a few weeks ago said he he met
some girl perfect thing you know
gorgeous great personality funny and all
that [ __ ] [ __ ] and then in the end he
found out that she did a little bit of
porn and and he broke up with her and he
felt [ __ ] bad about it but I just
it's just one of those things I would
bother me a heck of a lot less than the
Eiffel Tower scenario that this guy just
laid out so what are you saying it's
then this just your bodies your buddies
your what you gonna [ __ ] watch a
football game it's either that you could
get any time the team scores do you
think that they're mine it's much worse
when you know the people I think I mean
porn is a job or that but survival I
won't want more neither I mean I'm not
saying I would prefer not if you are the
origin before I met her so it's like but
if I had to choose one of the other
no-brainer give me the porn over the
point your buddies Eiffel towering a
girl yeah but you know some of those
pornstar chicks after a while they're
just so [ __ ] like I don't do the
lights out in there I you know what I
mean like just something happens I'm not
gonna sit here to say just can't ya know
what if you actually really loved her
and you just moved away and broke up
with your buddies ya know that's thingy
get rid of him but how can he love you
can't that's a deal Bernie
I could not do it that would haunt me
for the rest of my I gotta tell you
though he has great friends that the
fact that they told them before he got
too emotionally involved I know he says
he's coming out to the the place down
the Yacht Club this weekend I'm doing
this Giga thing I'd like to know what it
looks like when when you meet him how
does he introduced himself on the guy
with the girlfriend of that Eiffel
towered well cuz he wanted I've already
heard this podcast so you won't know I
don't know I don't know if you will well
I sent me a picture and we're gonna
judge you if you're ugly you won't or
even if he doesn't know I mean he he may
know you got the email like I said
an email about my girlfriend get Eiffel
Towers like that would be the intro yeah
I've actually I've had people do that it
gets they think they can get weird with
these things alright we got time for
another one here right all right did the
right thing basically you haven't seen
my girl in a week oh asking if I'd if he
did the right thing alright and you're a
[ __ ] champ for putting up with my
poor reading out loud skills here
alright bill did I do the right thing
basically haven't seen my girl in a week
there's this massive outdoor party slash
celebration going on in my city Calgary
where over a million people come and
basically just drink [ __ ] and party that
faces off for a week sounds like when
you're blackout yo and say and the
saying is like the one in Vegas what
happens in Calgary Stampede stays during
the Stampede alright here's the story
I'm trying to hang out with my girl all
day but she's busy no problem she
finally tells me her and a friend her
friends left her and she's alone I'm
watching the UFC fight but I decided to
get into a taxi and go find her and pick
her up then she says while I'm enroute
that she's actually at this bar with
this guy she met earlier on he lost his
friends - how convenient I thought she
said that it was the polite thing to do
to help him Jesus help him out which I
never understood basically they were out
getting trashed together at this bar I
pulled up in a taxi she was on the patio
with this out-of-town random guy at a
table and saw me and kind of drunkenly
stumbled over to the taxi whereby I
locked the door and just told her have
fun and rolled up the window and told
the taxi to leave went back to the usf
sea-fight had a great night
granted we aren't married but we you but
we have been dating seriously for the
past year or so what should I do
first of all do you think he did the
right thing at that at that moment to
roll the window up and drive away I
haven't lost me I was a long story with
he stay there all along yeah I was
actually somebody I was going to
compliment house to sink they put this
in I so he started at this how do you
get from the Stampede thing to the UFC
you know my awful reading you probably
zoned out for half a sec
that's not your fault he was it's a
Calgary Stampede thing it's the big
thing when everybody [ __ ] it up [ __ ]
each other he's at he's watching UFC
fight at home his girl tells him to come
down and [ __ ] meet him and then she
says oh my friends left me and then goes
oh I'm with this guy you know I don't
even [ __ ] remember at this point
[ __ ] friends left him was the thing I
got from me is once she ended up in the
cab with two groups of friends who left
no no she was still at the bar with the
guy she basically was at Adam ever left
yes she was at a bar she didn't get
leave by her friends she was with her
friends she met some hot guy I mean like
hey what happens in stampedes you know
have fun they [ __ ] take off she hangs
with this [ __ ] guy his friends are
going yeah and she goes oh my friends
left me here come and get me damsel in
distress so he stops watching the
pay-per-view fight goes down to get this
broad on the way over she drops the bomb
that she met some other guy who
conveniently got left by his friends and
the [ __ ] didn't she said that because
she then anar let's what the [ __ ]
going on so anyway so she [ __ ] comes
down he sees it says have a nice night
rolls up the [ __ ] window he saw them
just sitting there yeah Jesus Christ I
got a read it together
well it's there's so many things then
why didn't ya know buddy he did not do
the right thing just [ __ ] let her in
the car there at the same bar this girl
was at the bar what you call him pick me
up
he drove to the bar she's still at the
bar sitting at the bar in he went
Whipple with that guy but it's an
assault that guy I'm gonna totally
[ __ ] a good story it's no I get it but
who [ __ ] cares the guy was at the bar
you say who cares
alright this is good this is
point/counterpoint here I say he did the
right [ __ ] thing what because I
wasn't born yesterday
and I'm not saying you were I'm not
trying to insult you but like I'm just
like I know what the [ __ ] can go down in
a bar okay but why the [ __ ] especially
during Stampede week you know what that
means the very least he was rubbing a
[ __ ] over a [ __ ] first slacks you
have weird readers like what if this
pease thing is such a big deal in such
an awesome party why are you sitting
home at alone watching UFC in the middle
of [ __ ] Stampede week you're asking
for this girl to do whatever so what a
get fingered or whatever you just said
under the bar like it's it's Stampede
week go [ __ ] party don't sit home and
watch UFC but I'll see saying it's this
guy's fault that he that he was sitting
there like don't you they put a chastity
belt on or let her go out no not even
that I'm putting this in my shoes if I
have a girlfriend and she goes out for
Stampede week with her friends at a bar
says it you know whatever she said come
pick me up like I'm not gonna be pissed
if there's a dude sitting with her at
the table like it's a [ __ ] bar if she
want to hook up with him she wanted a
call I don't have that much faith in
women I just know what I I don't know I
just don't I don't I don't I've done so
I know what I've done with women in bars
in that situation when they don't call
me or I hung up I think every guy after
a while you've rounded third in a bar
weird then then why call you boyfriend
well I mean look it ain't about her it's
about this guy looks guys what I'm gonna
say he did the [ __ ] that was a strong
move he said have a nice night go [ __ ]
yourself is it right leash you gotta
just say it's not [ __ ] cool for you
to be doing that [ __ ] and you're gonna
and it's not my [ __ ] fault its [ __ ]
week and you decided to be your [ __ ]
that means if I go to Vegas on a
business trip that's your fault if you
let me [ __ ] go down there honestly if
I go to Vegas and I stay in my room to
watch UFC when she goes no Calgary
Calgary Stampede week so there's a bunch
of guys what happens at smelling like
[ __ ] oxen come into town no dude why
can't he go out what what and he can't
go but this is my thing my thing is is
if you have to give a gift if it's I I
will agree with that in a little bit but
I'll tell you this if it's [ __ ] [ __ ]
week alright and your if your girl can't
survive for week you don't have a
[ __ ] relationship anymore you don't I
mean I you know but could could could
your lovely wife go down to New Orleans
walk down Bourbon Street and still be a
faithful woman
good right yeah I hope so well there you
go but let me put this way I'm still not
if if I see a crew that she's going with
that's like six single girls she's like
hey we're going to [ __ ] New Orleans
or Vegas for the week and why I'm not
happy about that not at all no no so
this guy's sitting home this this is the
image of my I get it I get what you say
Hugh [ __ ] idiot yeah saying he's like
[ __ ] you I'm gonna go home and watch
more UFC fine by the time he [ __ ] pulled
out of the parking lot she's probably
getting rail for real this I'm gonna
continue to watch you know what I think
you might convince me I at least I like
his self-esteem and he's also he's
interrelationship [ __ ] you I want you to
fight I guess I guess the lesson here is
uh non [ __ ] night you have to protect
your [ __ ]
yeah dope yeah what happened pointed at
home right and what this guy still what
happens in Stampede week or whatever he
said stays in Stampede week all right
get your ass out a little living he's
saying what should I do
I I think it'd be I and I totally Davis
all you see your point but I I think you
know you made the mistake of trust in
your girl and when you can't trust
someone which you now realize you can't
it's over there's Michael Corleone's
says over it's over Godfather Part two
so I would get out of that so before we
wrap this up man I had a great time I
learning about your website and all the
type of stuff lunch and I'm always
psyched when I see somebody who got out
of the [ __ ] matrix right you had the
balls yeah that people I get I get it I
people read notes on that can I do this
can I do that like it just takes the
balls to go do it you just do a little
bit every [ __ ] day and you somehow
get this so before we get out of it I
got to talk Red Sox because I am elated
that they're they are tied for last
place right now because all I ever
wanted to do was see him win at once
they wanted [ __ ] twice and now if sea
level it's the Evan Evan flow you know
the old guard is gone now we got to
build up the new team and I'm starting
to see empty seats at the games and I'm
loving that because I wanted to go back
to not singing that douchey song during
the seventh inning no more pink Red Sox
hats and I want to be able to just walk
up and go to a [ __ ] game yeah I'm not
mad
there and last I mean I still root for
him but I not for the same reasons you I
don't I mean the they left just a sour
taste in my mouth after last year the
collapse hate back it hate him like
poison I don't even know that I can
really look for him as hard as I used as
long as he's on the team I loved when he
said it was my day off you like that I
loved it oh I hated that my day off go
[ __ ] yourself yeah that's exactly I
loved it he was saying [ __ ] you to you
yeah it was he wasn't saying to the fans
he was he what I don't like I don't know
that guy he's saying [ __ ] you to the
[ __ ] press stop sneaking around
follow me you bunch of [ __ ] gorgeous
nah he was he got scratched because it's
hurt he played golf and he makes twenty
million dollars a year and he didn't
even anyone a World Series force who
[ __ ] cares why do I do
no no I just be all I do I do
all I want to do is see him win it once
they want to [ __ ] it twice and they hung
a big biggest joke in professional
sports history on me no one will ever
talk to showing up at topic you can lose
four games in a row but you won't be a
215 million dollar team with four
first-ballot Hall of Famers you're not
just not going to be it's not gonna
happen again the only person who could
do it again is the [ __ ] Yankees
because they're the only ones who spent
200 million dollars who was a loving
staff on that it was the angle Red Sox
no the Red Sox it won we won it was
Schilling Bronson Arroyo Pedro Martinez
whoa Derek Lowe and Wakefield yes yeah
we was back in on that team no he was on
oh seven out so then who [ __ ] cares
because you already had your one you
don't care about your second then they
went oh you don't care for guys just so
he everybody says he's an [ __ ]
Universal from media defense area you
don't care
thousand bought like rooting for
somebody who's an [ __ ] doesn't bother
you at least I like beer and chicken too
yeah and if I could do it in between
podcasts we can look you know what you
know I think they I think they [ __ ] up
last year I think that they one of the
[ __ ] problems is is when [ __ ] goes
bad people don't accept the fact that
[ __ ] goes bad okay
and it's one of those deals where it's
not always going to be roses and
sometimes when it goes bad it doesn't
mean you got a [ __ ] dismantle
everybody like I think what the Red Sox
did after last year granted you got to
get rid of some people who aren't
[ __ ]
not earning their paychecks I definitely
understand that but to [ __ ] get rid
of everybody it's like now you know
everybody is not as good but Epstein
going the Cubs is not in a better
situation Tito I understand he was sick
of the media here at least but everybody
loved the media was the team well I
think everybody lost by the end it by
the end everybody goes their separate
ways
it's like watching you know was like it
was like watching a great band break up
was like watching David Lee Roth leave
[ __ ] Van Halen and then you I'm
watching Sammy Hagar who's alright but
he's not David Lee and then David Lee
Roth when he's in Van Halen he's a
[ __ ] rock star he gets out of that
thing he became a [ __ ] lounge singer
I'm telling you I I really believe that
that's what's gonna I think Tito is
gonna be fine but I just stand along
this groove of anything you said but
here's my point with the red socks I
think these guys make so much money
millions upon millions upon millions of
dollars and then it bothers me when they
[ __ ] about them I get the media but
guess what the media is what gives the
information of the fans the fans is why
you make so much money so just to blow
it off like with it's just a your talent
is why you make so much money
but if it listen you could be talented
at picking up trash and those guys don't
make the money that baseball that's a
unique weird talent like if I had
[ __ ] special stadiums yes right
correct but it's no different than
necessarily another talent that doesn't
make that it just happens you found
something that the American public is I
honestly think I remember reading this
thing where Ringo Starr drummer for The
Beatles just in case you know I know
okay he's [ __ ] he decided when he was
like 70 71 he goes I'm not signing any
more autographs I'm done and I remember
reading somebody wrote like this guy's
been sign autographs for 50 [ __ ]
years
somebody said because that's [ __ ]
[ __ ] because with the fans we're the
ones that made him famous like the fans
all got together and had a meeting and
went okay which band are we gonna make
famous it's like isn't it more that the
Beatles made music that was so [ __ ]
compelling you couldn't ignore it it's
like I think that like that that whole
[ __ ] philosophy that they're the ones
that they're the reasons why you make a
zillion dollars
they're not ok because I don't
have the power to make Michael Jordan
not make a zillion dollars that guy is
so [ __ ] unbelievable that you you
were gonna watch him you're gonna watch
Kobe you're gonna watch LeBron those
guys have like like you're talking 1 1
million to the [ __ ] population level
talent like Bret right and they and they
to the amount of hours and the sacrifice
and all this [ __ ] that they go through
and all the guys they got a [ __ ] beat
up to climb to the top of that mountain
and then the reward is orgies and money
correct absolutely but at no point do I
sit there and I go now LeBron you can
make it I have decided me no but it is
no it's not whether you make it it's the
collective interest it's without without
the interest in baseball which is really
irregardless of them like people love
baseball people love sports people love
music but without that demand you know
they're gonna make nothing and their
talent is is unique to what they do but
I fancy threatened to what we've
threatened to walk away and love it as
if we've got nothing better to do right
like I would love to [ __ ] turn my bat
and different times to have turned my
back on a bunch of different sports and
in the end of it I'm just alone with my
thoughts right and I have it was a it
was up to me I would a boy car to
college football till they got a real
[ __ ] playoff system that's like the
thing that bothers me the most it's
never gonna happen I agree with you it's
ingrained it's never gonna go away but
that doesn't mean like and you take a
different way I will get it is like
they're my client no way like uh they're
they're being paid to entertain me like
the press and part of it well let me ask
you this so now this guy is entertaining
you who okay oh the player yeah now what
responsibility you have because I don't
think that fans fans feel like I go buy
a ticket and that gives me a right to
dump of something in in Ron Artest face
where I would now I wait no one would
throw a drink and Ron Artest face in a
bar right no I'm all of a sudden II as a
New Jersey you feel like you can do that
you can feel like you can yell [ __ ]
about something me yeah this guy's you
say whatever you want it did you feel
like you can say when I don't think you
can thumb pad I don't know contact
nothing but you can be as mean
I completely disagree me okay well I
think if you think that you that you can
go like to the point of like when
somebody has a kid that was born with
some sort of you know a medical problem
I wanted that yeah but that's like the
type that's the type of [ __ ] that that
comes with that big bag of [ __ ] money
and my thing is what I would I see is
that media and the fans all want to hold
the athletes accountable but we don't we
don't like but we feel like whoa well
well then you shouldn't have got famous
you shouldn't have become a baseball
player and I and I should be able to
take out my miserable [ __ ] childhood
on you and you shouldn't turn around my
I think you should be able to take out
your miserable [ __ ] nine-to-five as
key folks at Burger King job on him
who's making twenty million to play kids
and you know I like that he said Burger
King job because he treated whoever
[ __ ] said whatever to him with the
same amount of respect but but but
that's that to me we look at different
ways like I have no pretty you know what
take that keep folk you can say if
someone wants to pay me twenty million
dollars I will stand up there you can
[ __ ] throw rocks at me how fine yeah
you're talking a good game talking a
good game go out and do it and do it day
after [ __ ] day is another thing it is
a thing you're gonna have to have people
like you remember how you felt in that
[ __ ] interview when that girl that's
was ran you you felt like you would have
your job every [ __ ] day III every if
you're the public eye that comes with it
like okay take it different like August
I want face to face but I mean I get
brutal I think it's really easy from
where we're sitting to be like dude you
know what I would do if I had that kind
dude I wouldn't give a [ __ ] the thing
about it is is once you make past a
certain amount of money it doesn't
[ __ ] a matter like how much more you
have and like you know buying a bunch of
shiny [ __ ] at the end of the day is not
gonna make you there's a few key things
look that I gotta make you happy in life
and one of them is is peace inner peace
and silence which you when you get to
that level of Fame okay you you don't
you don't really have that anymore
in certain [ __ ] [ __ ] have it like I
mean there's guys who aren't [ __ ]
Beckett going back to the example like
no one [ __ ] like Derek Jeter doesn't
get treated like Beckett does Beckett
and going back that example of the you
like one
fair enough like I'm like I was not
looking at that that there was there are
athletes there are [ __ ] okay alright
well I was kind of playing devil's
advocate there okay I mean I don't think
people I mean you look at and Ortiz is
kind of yapping a lot this year but I
mean he's people loving there's beloved
athletes but then there's [ __ ]
athletes and all I'm saying you go to
like the Beckett when he was her like
coming off what happened last her and
all the fried chicken all the hoopla and
all the media he's innocent he missed a
start because it was hurt and then he
went golfing to me that's just I don't
give a [ __ ] about anybody that's all he
said oh I don't think the beer or
anything last year had anything to do
with them stinking I think everyone
drinks I just look at it like you know
this is gonna be a story like you're
you're Robbie didn't know he was gonna
get heat you know he got caught he got
caught like like a [ __ ] calling his
own phone's going it's like you know
when somebody fakes a back injury I
machine a guy like they was showing
these insurance fraud things was [ __ ]
hilarious this guy faked a back injury
he was so in this insurance company and
then he goes out and goes golfing and
the warm-up exercise he was doing he was
something it was so [ __ ] less is I
got a visually I can explain this to
people it was he had the club you know
behind his neck on his shoulders with
his hands hanging over and he was doing
those these psycho like Taekwondo twists
and it and they all just showed him
lifting something heavy out of his trunk
like yeah I think he had like you know
charcoal to barbecue like the guy was
just living the [ __ ] life that was
hilarious look I'm not saying you like I
think he owes the same reason why I like
what I like like I think a lot of people
cowering from the press I'm not saying
where the guy was right or whether he
was wrong I loved it I love you just
kept going through it's my day off I'll
do whatever the [ __ ] I want to like that
taps into my yeah go [ __ ] yourself I
don't like having a boss now I know yeah
he shouldn't have done that he got
caught he should have owned up to it he
should have probably handled it better
but just as a comedian watching somebody
to tell a crowd to go [ __ ] themselves
there's always something about that that
that that does make me laugh but this is
my thing like when you tie favors to go
[ __ ] like in an angry way like the
people who buy a ticket to this
this is what I would say I used to
always go you know what I love about mom
and pops places you know the customer's
always right
and I talked to a guy who owned a place
and he goes no he goes right is right
and I was like you know what you are
right begin and I think that if fans I'm
generalizing fans should have more right
is right okay
don't expect this guy we made tonight
okay he can't eat chicken and drink beer
before a [ __ ] start but you can make
fun of his kid who has [ __ ] autism I
mean give me a [ __ ] break and well I
paid for a ticket that's your fault for
making it as a baseball player and I can
sit here with no [ __ ] responsibility
what's so [ __ ] ever and act like a
total [ __ ] and throw a drink in your
face and not expect the guy to come in
and stands and punch me in the [ __ ]
face like like I agree with you I
thought I agree probably are I do that
like my goodness if if someone says
something like that had no problem the
play going and beating a guy if a guy
won't answer a question why [ __ ] golf
when he was hurt that's a different
thing for me but I would need yeah you
shouldn't there there is a line that
just normal and this is almost like goes
full circle I guess I think like
rationally like but I don't a non
rational person like you're not normal
if you go to that extreme like hey your
[ __ ] kid has autism that's like a
[ __ ] idiot like that's just a [ __ ]
lunatic idiot that nobody should sound
those racist after the Bruins game yeah
right yeah exactly
so that's alright we're a hundred
percent on the same page there I'm
talking more like sometimes guys get mad
when they get booed and [ __ ] it's like
really no no no that bad no then you're
being a [ __ ] I'm not and I'm not saying
the reason why I'm going so hard
defendant athletes on this is just
because I feel like that like this side
isn't presented it's never any sort of
like a fan has any sort of
responsibility like what about like
walking up for an autograph when he's
eating dinner I think eating dinner is a
sacred thing you don't do it I think if
they're if they're walking down the
[ __ ] Street that's part of the game
but if they're sitting there at dinner
like I I think people pee even people
know that you know when I was in San
Francisco I [ __ ] was in a restaurant
Joe Montana was two tables away whose
[ __ ] unreal and somebody asked me
Justin for autograph and I jokingly said
I wouldn't ask screech for an autograph
if he was talking
I'm not messing which I wouldn't I
wouldn't [ __ ] with the like me what do I
do I'm assigned my napkin and then look
like I meant more of the thing I
wouldn't have ruined his appetizer I'm
down a napkin I'm gonna lose
I wouldn't ask either but I hope if I
ever became that famous which I
obviously won't but if you did or
somebody did I hope I would never get
mad either it's like that it's
absolutely there's always what how you
would hope but like I think that like
the only way to truly understand what
it's like cuz you know dude I mean
nobody [ __ ] bumps me when I'm [ __ ]
like I have like a cult following in
comedy clubs and other than that nobody
knows who the [ __ ] I am so I have this
great I mean I'm in the perfect place in
this business
I'm known enough where I can sell
tickets and make a good living but I
walk around and nobody [ __ ] with me but
I've been around you know with certain
events where I've done stand-up with
super [ __ ] famous people and dude it
doesn't look like fun it looks like it
looks like they never look comfortable
and they just want to get the [ __ ] out
of there and it's one of those things
why people go well then why the [ __ ] did
you become a musician why did you do
that and and my answer to that would be
like when when you start out what you
think being famous is and then what it
really is is for the most part miles and
miles apart and then when you see like
like just from when I start well I start
dude know me I guess there was the
[ __ ] Internet but I started 92 there
was no cellphones with his biggest is
[ __ ] chair right there was none of
these cameras and like film and stuff
and like it's like everybody's become
like these spies and like I mean like
that hasn't affect my world but like
when I look I've seen guys who are like
it's just everywhere they [ __ ] go
people see and they'll just come walking
up to you like filming you yeah yeah say
what's up to my man yeah and I think
after a while like they just like
anything it just it just [ __ ] you it's
like look dude I get it right I totally
appreciate it if I just want to [ __ ]
chill here and and have something to eat
and it's one of those things that but
for the on the fan side it's like dude
I've been rooting for you you know I'm
spending money on you Jersey I put money
in your [ __ ] pocket this is my
five-second window where I'm gonna see
you you know make this five seconds of
my life and I think people are human and
they don't let they don't let those guys
be he
where every once in a while yeah I mean
I would not gonna get so much [ __ ] on
your [ __ ] people on the web's no no I
mean I think you're doing you straddle
offense both ways so I don't think you
will get [ __ ] I mean I just and we are
in that world I mean we're an Internet
so that's all living with people take
your cut you're a [ __ ] and you should be
treated like one but I think sometimes
you know on either way you know fans
banya you're not [ __ ] hitting and
that that comes with it if you cry about
that you're a [ __ ] but like but you go
to a game and you're yelling that type
of [ __ ] you know about people's families
or you know other things like you know
like they see then they find out like
psycho fans find out like what you know
they know what their wives look like her
ass in a minute no it's all over there's
extremes on both sides I mean and then
you have athletes guys like Charles
Barkley uniformly everyone says is
awesome like it's almond Daisy
Buchanan's here those few years ago when
he was blue is he playing for at that
point it might even been the scylla
76ers and he was just hanging out and he
was cool as hell you know what's funny
he didn't make a big deal out of the
fact that he was Charles Barkley so he's
the raw goat so so nobody rushed him and
I think when you come in you know with
like felt ropes around you I think you
actually build up to - we're gonna go
like on for an hour and 16 here all
right wrapping it up here Dave so
[ __ ] nice to meet you thanks for
letting me swing by here
barstoolsports.com and with if people
out there who are insane about sports
and you want to start you want to get
out of your miserable life in that
[ __ ] cubicle and I actually write
about something or you always wanted to
write or whatever you think you can do
it where should they send it to tips at
barstoolsports.com t IPS at barstools
sports calm that's the Monday morning
podcast go [ __ ] yourselves I'll talk to
you next week
and that's it let me shut this thing off
here
you